and it was leukemia i remember that and
it was just like another like just nice
and i was just like
so the first half of 2020
first half all of 2020 yeah was [ __ ]
horrible
and then james calls me in october and
he's like we're doing
peacemaker and i was like and you were
rock bottom at this point at this point
this is the lowest you've been since
you've been this is
the worst year of my life 2020 and then
james like completely
pulls me out of like a [ __ ] pit
and he's like yeah i was like all right
when are we doing it he's like in three
months
wow and i was just like good get me the
[ __ ] out of here
and that was seven months of getting to
hang out with james and jen and
cena and a lot of work
yeah pretty exhausting
at times but it was it's an ensemble so
and they would block shoot episodes so
it'd be like
there'd be like two weeks where they're
doing all this stuff at a prison and i'm
in none of those scenes so it'd be like
just driving around british columbia
taking photos right you know yeah you
can look on his instagram and a lot of
those photos that are still there at
steve agee at steve agee um
you know i watched the first four how
many have aired at this point well i
don't know but they will have all aired
by this point
yeah six just when this airs
um
i was so
happy to see how good you were oh thanks
man because you know your friends you
work with your friends and i always
think oh steve's hilarious i love being
around steve steve's a great guy i love
him
he's a character actor i only see him
one line at a time and now i see you and
it's like you're going toe-to-toe
there's some scenes with you and and
see i almost said joe spina but uh
cena
let's just start calling cena or
spinacina spina it's called cena and
jose but seeing you in these scenes it's
just like and it's not one-dimensional
it's like you could see this character
kind of hurt at times yeah physically as
asthma falling against the wall and like
you know being abused and like getting
emotional getting hurt his feelings hurt
casinos throwing [ __ ] at him peacemaker
is making fun of him his beard being
died yeah wait till the finale dude i
don't say anything no no i'm not saying
anything but like there's just a full
arc like it's a great character i'm so
lucky